jared leto reportedly had trouble
putting on a happy face when hearing
about the new joker movie according to a
story published by The Hollywood
Reporter detailing how former Joker
producer Martin Scorsese may have
contributed to the film after dropping
his producing credit Jared Leto who
played the Joker in 2016 Suicide Squad
was none too pleased about studio Warner
Brothers moving forward with the Joker
origin story film starring Joaquin
Phoenix reportedly Leto was left feeling
out in the cold when former Warner
Brothers President Kevin Sugihara and
current studio chief Toby Emmerich
decided to give the project the
greenlight Emmerich is said to have
quote loved the script that Phillips
co-wrote with Academy Award nominated
screenwriter Scott Silver though he did
reportedly feel that the gritty nature
of the story might fit better outside of
the standard DC extended universe of
which Suicide Squad is apart nonetheless
Emmerich was taken with Joker as was
Sugihara and the rest is history
neither Leto nor any representatives of
his have come forward to confirm or
denied a claim that he was hurt over the
Phoenix led Joker but the actors
purported reaction to hearing the news
of the project getting the greenlight
may be accurate given past Joker related
events as fans know Leto's Joker didn't
have nearly as prominent a role in
Suicide Squad as expected his
involvement essentially amounted to an
extended cameo rather than a starring
part which left audiences and Leto
disappointed and confused Oh
I'm just gonna hurt you really really
director David Ayer even admitted that
he should have included more of Leto's
Joker in the film in an open letter
published in January 2017 Ayer wrote
wish I had a time machine I'd make Joker
the main villain and engineer a more
grounded story I have to take the good
and bad and learn from it that
considered one can easily see how Leto
may have felt alienated and upset when
Warner Brothers chose to go ahead with
Phillips and Phoenix's Joker movie the
idea for which Phillips pitched to
Warner Brothers in August 2016 the same
month that Suicide Squad opened in
theaters learning one year later that a
different actor would get the chance to
play the Joker in his very own solo
movie very well might have crushed Leto
spirits even if Warner Brothers
executives emphasized that the project
wouldn't be the end of Leto's Joker
shortly after Warner Brothers and DC
films made the announcement about the
Joker standalone film The Hollywood
Reporter ran a piece noting that Leto
made sure his agents knew he wasn't
happy with the idea of multiple
competing Joker's Leto later told
on-demand entertainment that he was
quote a little confused about the future
plans for the Joker which at the time
included a spin-off movie featuring his
Joker and Margot Robbie's Harley Quinn
however he maintained a level head he
admitted I loved the Joker he's a great
character and really fun character to
play but it's a big universe and when
you play the Joker
there's no ownership there you have the
honor of holding the baton for a little
while and then passing it off there are
other films that are in development and
I'm excited to see what comes from them
i sweet-talking me
letõs disposition likely turned sunny in
June 2018 when it was reported that
Warner Brothers was developing a
standalone Joker movie featuring letõs
iteration of the infamous DC Comics
villain the project which Leto was also
set to be credited on as an executive
producer was apparently intended to be
the first of several Suicide Squad
offshoots unfortunately it appears that
both the Joker Harley Quinn spin-off
film and the Joker solo flick starring
Leto have since been scrapped in
February 2019 forms ran a piece noting
that both projects had quote fallen by
the wayside at Warner Brothers as of
October 2019 we don't know for certain
what the future holds for Leto's Joker
the easiest bet is that he could appear
in James Gunn's upcoming sequel / reboot
the Suicide Squad which features a mix
of returning characters and fresh faces
there's been no formal announcement
about his possible involvement though so
it's a toss-up whether or not Leto will
grace the silver screen and Flash
Joker's silver teeth in 2021 the Suicide
Squad check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite comic book movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]